[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: In this
video, we're going
to walk through how to
add, change, or delete
a billing account
from a Google Cloud
project using the console.
In order to perform
these tasks, you'll
need to be a project
owner or project billing
manager on the project and a
billing account administrator
or billing account user for
the target billing account.
Get started by heading
into the Cloud console.
You can start on any
project homepage.
Then head to the Navigation
menu in the left-hand pane,
choose Billing, and then
click Manage Billing Accounts.
You can also access
this same destination
from the billing overview
page by expanding the dropdown
list of Billing Accounts and
clicking on Manage Billing
Accounts.
Select the My Projects tab to
view a list of your projects.
You'll also see the associated
Cloud billing account
for each project.
If you have a project for which
billing is currently disabled,
you can re-enable it by
clicking on the three-dot menu
and selecting Change Billing.
In the dropdown, choose
the desired billing account
and click Set Account.
You can also change the billing
account currently attached
to a project following
a similar process.
Identify the project and
click the three-dot menu
and select Change Billing.
In the dropdown, choose the
desired destination billing
account and click Set Account.
If you would like to remove a
billing account from a project,
or in other words, disable
billing, identify the project
and click the three-dot menu.
Then select Disable Billing.
You'll be asked to confirm that
you want to disable billing
for this project.
A quick word of caution--
disabling billing
on a project might
cause some resources to
be removed and become
non-recoverable.
When you are ready,
click Disable Billing.
If at any time the options
to change billing or disable
billing are not
available to you,
this means you may not
have the permissions needed
to make this change.
In that case, be sure to review
the permissions requirements
shared at the beginning
of this video.
Head over to the documentation
to check out more details.
[MUSIC PLAYING]